l'examen du projet de loi transformant
le pass sanitaire en passe vaccinale ne
s'est pas passé l'écueil
lundi 3 janvier olivier ferrand
souhaitait poursuivre les débats toute
la nuit afin de mettre en place ce
nouveau dispositif au plus vite le mans
le gouvernement demande à prolongation
de la séance en cours au delà de minuit
le ministre de la santé a alors
sollicité l'accord de l'hémicycle via un
vote à main levée je consulte
l'assemblée sur cette demande qui est
pour et qui est contre mais une majorité
de députés à refuser l'aperçu des débats
consiste en
une suspension surprise saluée par
l'opposition mais qui ne devrait pas
remettre en cause le projet de loi
l'entrée en vigueur du pass vaccinale
prévu initialement pour le 15 janvier
pourrait cependant être décalés
[Applaudissements]